so one of the things I looked at in
detail over the weekend is the latest
fur form or version of Joe Biden's tax
plan and I want to dig into it with you
because you know we've talked about
taxation in the United States many many
times and I've talked about what I think
would be the right path forward for the
changes we need to make to how people
are taxed and there's this assumption
that Joe Biden would be extremely
centrist in terms of his policy and in
some cases that's true and certainly on
many issues Joe Biden is is well to
Bernie Sanders right but I have to tell
you that Joe Biden's tax plan if made
law and again with any candidate we
would we would always say if made law
everything is negotiated no president
gets exactly what they want Joe Biden's
tax plan maybe one of the most
progressive from the standpoint of
taxing millionaires and in particular
non-working millionaires then any tax
plan that we have seen in the modern
political era even including Dwight D
Eisenhower when we had that top marginal
tax rate of 91% and I'm gonna explain
this and and I'm not what I'm looking
here is not to soda vision but rather to
point out that Joe Biden's tax plan is
really quite solid and and would do a
lot to tax the people that most should
be taxed from the progressive
perspective a lot of times the debate
over taxes over the last 20 years has
been should the richest pay 39 or 36
percent 39.6 or 37 percent like that's
the debate that is 80 percent of the
debate when we talk about rolling back
the Bush tax cuts or rolling back the
Trump what we're mostly talking about
for a lot of people right I think it's
about 500,000 and up in income is should
the richest pay 36 or 39 percent this
ignores capital gains this ignores that
we need higher and higher and bigger tax
brackets etc etc etc let's look now at
some of the things that Joe Biden has in
his tax plan now I want to remind you
Dwight the Eisenhower had these high top
marginal tax rates of like 90 percent
but he had them at a time where the
were a ton of mechanisms to avoid
actually paying a high effective tax
rate if you were very wealthy so when
you look back at the what matters is the
effective tax rate if you look back at
the Eisenhower era even though you had
those high marginal tax rates the top 1%
of taxpayers in the 50s we're only
paying about 42% total of their income
in taxes so as a result the tax burden
on high-income households today is only
slightly lower than what those same top
1% paid in the 1950s and what Joe Biden
is proposing to do could raise taxes on
the rich well beyond what they were
under the Eisenhower 91% top marginal
tax rate days because as you can see
since the early 90s the effective tax
rate on the top 1% has bounced between
35 and 40 percent okay so what will Joe
Biden's tax plan do number one yes it
will undo those Trump brackets that are
similar to the george w bush brackets
the top tax rate will go from 37 percent
to 39.6 percent it's the right move it's
not that big of a thing for a large
swath of Americans the very important
change that Biden would make is that
earnings above 400,000 would be subject
to the Social Security tax of 12.1
percent
this is monstrous in terms of the total
amount of money right now you stopped
paying Social Security tax at about a
hundred and thirty seven thousand
dollars in income you pay it on your
first hundred and thirty seven K then it
goes to zero what Biden proposes is
there's a doughnut hole there between a
hundred and thirty seven and four
hundred thousand where you don't pay
that twelve percent tax but then when
you get to four hundred thousand dollars
in income and going all the way up you
pay twelve point one percent that is
absolutely massive in terms of the
amount of money that would collect and
that money would be used to increase the
social security benefits for the poor so
that would actually remove hundreds of
thousands of seniors from poverty it
costs the middle class
zero and it comes from people earning
over 400,000 now you might correctly say
but but David hold on a second sir
as Donald Trump says David a lot of the
rich are the non-working rich they're
not earning wages so they wouldn't be
affected by that and you're completely
correct the other thing that Joe Biden's
tax plan would do is remove the lower
capital gains rate on dividends and the
long-term capital gains rate if you make
over 1 million dollars per year so the
non-working millionaires would be paying
in dramatically more money because they
would have to pay their income tax rate
rather than the capital gains rate on a
whole bunch of dividends and capital
gains this could double the tax rate for
non-working millionaires who get most of
their income from investments also very
importantly Biden is calling for a full
repeal of stepped-up basis now what did
this requires a little bit of
explanation but what this means is if
someone donates imagine that someone
buys a thousand dollars worth of stock
in the 1970s they die and they give you
a million dollars worth of stock that's
a huge gain right it went from a
thousand to a million dollars there's a
cartoonish example what the stepped-up
basis allows is that if you is the heir
with that stock decide to sell it at a
time when it's worth 1 point 1 million
dollars stepped-up basis allows you to
only pay gains on the gain from the time
you inherited the stock to the time that
you sell it so even though the person
who gave you the stock the stock went
from a thousand dollars to a million
dollars in value when you got it it was
worth a million and it went up to 1.1
you only pay capital gains on that
hundred thousand dollars from a million
to one point one that is a massive
massive handout on which taxes could be
levied and it is not and it is estimated
to be if a Joe Biden were to eliminate
the the stepped-up basis
provision that would be more than four
trillion dollars of a tax increase on
the rich so joe biden's tax plan
actually does a lot of good now let's be
thorough it doesn't do a lot of things
that we should be looking at that other
candidates have proposed joe biden has
not proposed the financial transaction
tax a little slice which could be used
to fund all sorts of important programs
joe biden doesn't do that joe biden has
found or joe biden's plan does not
include higher tax brackets with higher
interest rates so right now if you you
would cap out around six hundred
thousand dollars with a thirty with
Biden's tax funded be thirty nine point
six percent you pay beyond six hundred
thousand dollars in earnings we probably
should have a tax bracket at forty
percent between six hundred thousand and
a million in earnings we should have a
forty five percent tax bracket between
one and three million
etc Joe Biden doesn't do that I think
that we need that and then number three
to the dismay of some people Joe Biden's
plan doesn't include
a wealth tax now I actually don't think
a wealth tax would ever pass so so while
it's an interesting idea I'm not going
crazy because Joe Biden doesn't include
it but if we look at the reality if we
look at the analysis that the Tax Policy
Center has done of this plan three
quarters of the increases fall on the
richest 1% and a whole bunch of that
other twenty five percent is on the top
five percent this is a very progressive
tax plan compared to what we've seen
certainly for the last 50 even a hundred
years in the United States I'm not
saying Joe Biden is the greatest period
but let's be honest and look at the tax
plan for what it is